Phu v let lịch sử định cao diếp lễ 3 tháng tư để 1 táng 5 năm nay trước chắn gọi trên VGO Lę sinh đồng hối.
Tụi thường tâm in ngàn người dân và dù khách đồng về kiến đặc không dàng,
sêu sâu ba đến nhật nước ba đêm mắt bình tại VGO Lę sinh đồng hối thực sự đã thạo nên một cơ sốt trong kiến nghĩ lễ vừa qua.
Không chỉ gây trong ngợp bởi bí mô hoành trang với dàng anh sang lę dơ và những cuộc nước tương cao hàng chục mết,
điều khiến hàng chực năng nguy có mặt tại đây thực sự nguy ra ra.
Chính là khoảng khác lịch sử hào vùng của rất tộc đột tán hiện của các sống động và thương liên này trên mạnh nước hộ lâu các người phóng hà làm dịch sáng bộ trời đồng hối,
vô sâu anh mắt chẳng chứ nước nhìn hà cùng nghiệp đập thương hãi của chế tư người Việt.
Cố phó lấy xung công nghệ điên cao để tôn vình lịch sử nước nhà này của vô Lę sinh đồng hối trước chắn là khoảng khác ấn tượng và tự hào nhất trong gì bếm năm này.
Với mừng một mắt mình phút tâm ta phía ngua ạm,
lãnh chiến dwing đặc lập bộ tấn thăm của người,
giữ bắt mình đo hành vô điều kè,
cơ đảo sang vàn hộ hối tục bài trên đau dinh đặc lập chiến dịch hồ chiến mình gặn thắng.